is an A-list celeb but when it comes to
momming she's hashtag relatable how do
you raise a kid in today's society
that's not going to come out to be a
natural the actress who shares two
kiddos with her hubby Ashton Kutcher
eight-year-old daughter Wyatt and
five-year-old son Dimitri stop by the
Kelly Clarkson show and kept it real
about managing their chaotic schedules
tell me if this is in your school
this thing of like if you invite one kid
to a birthday party you have to invite
the classroom oh yeah yeah yeah that's
got to go like that's it I'm so so I'm
sorry I love everyone in my kids school
please I'm so sorry don't don't hate me
but it's too much you get invited to 22
kids birthday parties then there's like
the classroom play dates and then
there's like the other place there's
like they're very busy and she reveals
the secret to juggling it all we
sometimes lie to our kids we don't lie
that's a horrible thing to say I don't
lie to my children I mean what parent
hasn't told a little white lie to get
out of a playdate I was like relax and
while the actress jokingly backtracked a
bit on her admission Kelly Clarkson who
shares two kids with her ex Brandon
Blackstock not only said ditto she
doubled down on it I totally lied to my
children I totally I'm outside I'm like
oh Disneyland's closed today oh my God
no you don't yeah yeah I I don't I'm not
above it you can tell totally judge me
write a book on it I don't care I
totally lie to my children I love you so
much we just tell our kids we have plans
when we don't and then when that's life
they're gonna think that their mom likes
to do nothing but watch movies because
it's the only time like when we get home
either we're playing a game or like
watching a movie together because I'm so
tired as for Mila she says they found
the perfect excuse for getting out of
those endless birthday parties and play
dates we also now have the excuse of
football which is Sunday's football
Thursday nights football Monday nights
but football's on a lot in America
nowadays yep and um so we're like
there's a football game on this college
football on Saturday why can't we go to
Johnny's House football I gotta watch
football see I don't get that one
because I I don't really watch a ton of
football
thanks to life but this is hardly the
first time Mila has shared her parenting
tricks you say everyone's here while
you're filming you like to have the
family around yeah we're like a we're a
mobile tribe so how do you guys
entertain yourselves what do you do when
you're not working I can write to a book
on all kid-friendly activities anywhere
in the world because that's what we do
we used to be like what's the coolest
club and I'm like let me tell you about
the zoo in Atlanta there's not one kid
activity you're gonna tell me that I
haven't done yet we have a public
library card everywhere we go and you
guys I know you're trying you're hoping
to raise you know open-minded
civic-minded individuals so the library
so yeah great yeah we're not going to
raise there's enough souls in this world
we don't need to contribute you know
over the years Mila's been an open book
about Mom life every night that we put
Wyatt down we high-five each other and
we're like we did it every single day we
kept her alive we're like she's alive
and we're still in love like it's you
high five when you still like each other
and you still like your kid at the end
of the night because sometimes they're
the devil well she has a lot to high
five Ashton about these days I have a
really great husband I really do Mila's
new flick luckiest girl live is
streaming on Netflix and no one's more
stoked for her than her other half wifey
has a new film out on Netflix it's
called luckiest girl alive and it is uh
it rocks she just crushed this role it
was really
what are you doing I'm getting the dogs
I'm trying to make a video to support
and be supportive of your feature film
that you keep doing that I'm gonna go
get the dogs
you're getting distracted say nice
things about me and up next the couple
is working together again revisiting
their roles as Kelso and Jackie on
Netflix's that 90s show which will
feature their characters all grown up
with a kid did it like freak your head a
little bit when you said okay I'm going
back to do this and now I'm married to
this man
let me tell you first and foremost my
child without giving too much away in
this show is way too old to be my child
so I was like what what are we like teen
pair like
so okay I was like whatever so first of
all my kids way too old I want everybody
to know not possible
um it's very good it's great in fact and
I think that anyone that's never watched
70s that was a fan loved it I think
would be very very very very happy with
how they the inciting incident of this
of the whole series
[Music]